[Music]
on this Monday night to Serve and
Protect the new pledge to improve police
services for indigenous communities my
community is living in fear the
obstacles they're facing
Russia's brutal new bombardments on
Ukraine's capital
Terror and how ukrainians fought back
who knew what and when new evidence the
city of Ottawa and police were too slow
to stop the Convoy protests
and the new UK prime minister versus a
vegetable I guess it depends quite how
long the list can last the Brits betting
she'll be Iceberg out
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
six weeks after 11 people were killed
and 18 others hurt in a stabbing
massacre in James Smith Cree Nation and
the nearby Village of Weldon indigenous
leaders in Saskatchewan and the federal
and provincial governments have
committed to work on a better way to
provide Police Services Prince Albert
Grand Council which represents 12 First
Nations and 28 communities signed an
agreement with the federal Public Safety
Minister and the province the goal is to
develop plans to create more
indigenous-led police services and make
First Nations communities safer
we want to come into the community and
do that evaluation making sure that we
engage with the Grassroots people and
talk about how do we make our community
safe that's what it's about
then hopefully eventually lead to a
self-administered community-based
policing in the future
that first phase of the project
Community engagement and Outreach will
start before the year is over there are
more than 630 indigenous communities in
Canada but fewer than 40 indigenous
police services in western Canada there
are just a handful of locally LED forces
a situation many blame on the barriers
created by the federal funding structure
Global's Heather urac's West visited
sutina first nation in Alberta a
community served by its own police force
she got a first-hand look at how it
operates and how it can be a model for
other First Nations
inspector Clint Healy and acting
Sergeant Tim Daly consider themselves
part of the satina First Nation
Community though neither are from here
daily is non-indigenous Healy is from
the nearby six Sika First Nation but
they've both worked in satina every day
for years or what all the community
events you know you know we're you know
going to the funerals I think that's the
benefit of having
um you know your own Community Police
Service is because we're all dedicated
to being here we've been here a long
time we know the community members and
community members know us
the satina nation Police Service has
been a part of this Reserve since 2004.
75 percent of its staff and about 50
percent of officers are indigenous and
First Nations culture features heavily
in how police work is done when we have
a new officer come in
we also have one of our elders as part
of the swearing-in ceremony and that
Elder is mentoring that police officer
and the police officer can go to that
Elder with any knowledge that they need
any questions that they may have pretty
Central it's a model that works but
across the country this kind of policing
is pretty rare there are only 36
indigenous administered police services
in Canada but most of them are in
Ontario and Quebec it means most
indigenous communities across western
Canada rely on the RCMP so Manitoba has
one Saskatchewan has one we here in
Alberta have three self-administered and
in BC they have one
when violence erupted last month on the
James Smith Cree Nation officers had to
be dispatched from a community 45
kilometers away it took about 30 minutes
for the first officers to arrive we
asked that
we have our own tribal policing and the
James Smith Cree Nation isn't alone a
month after the mass killing there a
second Saskatchewan First Nation sounded
an alarm the gangs and the drugs are
come to a point in my community where my
community is living in fear at a press
conference on October 5th the Buffalo
River DNA Nation declared a state of
emergency around Community safety
policing needs to be an essential
service on every First Nation not only
in this region but in this country
because as it stands now indigenous
policing is not considered essential the
satina nation Police Service is
classified as a program meaning its
Federal funding isn't guaranteed year to
year that funding is also subject to
restrictive terms that non-indigenous
Police Services just don't face we're
not able or allowed to form specialty
units so if we have a major crime that
occurs here we would need and likely
require some support Chief Blake says
his officers just want to be treated
like everybody else so they can do the
locally focused culturally appropriate
police work so many indigenous
communities need
Heather urich's West Global News on the
satina First Nation Alberta
the federal government is working with
the Assembly of First Nations and the
First Nation Chiefs of police to draft
new legislation that would declare First
Nations policing as an essential service
to Ukraine now Russia escalated its
aerial bombardment using drones to
attack the capital during the morning
Rush Ukraine says iranian-made drones
are targeting civilians and crippling
key infrastructure away from the front
lines and police are trying to shoot
them down
at least four people were killed as
Crystal gomancing Reports the fresh
round of air strikes is adding pressure
to the west to punish Iran and deliver
more military aid to Ukraine
disturbing cell phone video some
confirmed and some not yet verified
flooded social media the images showing
the terrifying and deadly unmanned
drones deployed by Russia
Kamikaze drones are designed to explode
on impact Ukraine's Air Force claims
more than 40 of the iranian-made devices
were deployed Monday morning
ukrainians responded by trying to shoot
the drones out of the sky
the start of the week brought with it
another frantic search for survivors
we came here after getting a phone call
from our mother who said she was under
the rubble she said please find someone
urgently to help me their mother stopped
answering the phone
we were in the room when the blast
started then we go out to see the
staircases gone all gone down to the
ground floor firefighters eventually
rescued them using ladders brushes is
their country I'm more than sure do you
see the unhealthy people killed every
day in not just on Keith everywhere
anyway Russia says it hit military
command sites Communications and energy
infrastructure with long-range High
Precision weapons like many ukrainians
the foreign affairs minister heeded the
warning sirens and sought safety
underground Demetrio khalib posted to
social media that he might be the first
to address the European Union from a
bomb shelter Ukraine wants the EU to
sanction Iran for selling drones to
Russia Iran denies the sale and the EU
is investigating the United States one
of Ukraine's biggest weapons suppliers
meanwhile is keeping the focus on Russia
this war can end today this is a war
that contend right now today if uh if if
Vladimir Putin wants it to nearly eight
months into this war and every day comes
with a threat
Crystal commencing Global News London
city of Ottawa officials took the stand
today as the public inquiry into the
federal government's controversial use
of the emergencies act enters its second
week Mercedes Stevenson reports
[Music]
while there were bouncy castles and hot
tubs the inquiry into the use of the
emergencies Act is learning more about
darker concerns police and security
agencies had about who and what may have
infiltrated the protest
the Parliamentary Protective Service
responsible for protecting Parliament
Hill was astonished by the city of
ottawa's decision to move more than 200
trucks directly in front of Parliament
and the prime minister's office worried
about potential vehicle bombs calling it
a clear disregard to security and noting
we just finished a Bomb Blast assessment
which included the threat of explosives
being transferred via large Vehicles the
city of Ottawa and Ottawa Police have
long defended their approach claiming
last Winter's Convoy blockade was an
unprecedented event but striking
testimony and documents entered into
evidence Monday appear to blatantly
contradict their claims the former Chief
of the police once said the Convoy
protests were unforeseen but documents
filed today show the city and its police
force knew well in advance of the Convoy
that thousands of protesters were
heading to Ottawa and plan to stay for
months it wasn't unusual to have a a
variance in the uh views of people who
thought it was going to be bigger longer
you know smaller documents show that
Ottawa Police were anticipating around
800 trucks participating but still did
not close down access to downtown Ottawa
Ottawa city manager testified he was
made aware of a surge in long-term hotel
bookings and a January 25th email
forwarded to the mayor's office warned
that around 10 000 demonstrators planned
to stay in Ottawa for 30 to 90 days
the city was also warned by a protest
organizer who approached them saying the
Convoy planned to camp out at Parliament
Hill indefinitely and that they wanted
to attempt citizens arrests on prime
minister Trudeau
when the trucks did dig in we heard
testimony today the city didn't bother
trying to ticket them assuming it would
achieve little and could agitate other
demonstrators the city of Ottawa also
delayed filing an injunction fearing it
did not have the resources to move the
trucks if it was granted today evidence
showed that some of the RCMP sent to the
Capitol to help did not deal with the
protest but rather protected Federal
buildings the commission continues to
Morrow with more questions about whether
politicians should have met with some of
the demonstrators Mercedes Stevenson
Global News Ottawa
ballots in a Battleground coming up
early voters in Atlanta on the fierce
fight in the midterm elections
[Music]
in the U.S the first day of early voting
for next month's midterm elections is
now underway in Georgia there have been
big lines from the moment polls opened
at 7 A.M the race for governor is a
rematch between Republican incumbent
Brian Kemp and Democrat Stacey Abrams
and the run for Senate seeing Democratic
incumbent Raphael Warnock trying to keep
his seat against controversial
Republican Challenger Herschel Walker
Jackson prosco is at a polling station
for us tonight in Atlanta Jackson how
was the first day of turnout and what
are voters you spoke to saying about who
they're voting for and why well need to
keep in mind that we are more than three
weeks out from election day today is the
first day of early voting and yet what
we've seen are these incredible lines
more than an hour to vote here in
Atlanta sources tell me in some of the
outlying suburbs that people waited more
than three hours to cast a ballot today
really what's driving voters to the
polls are three factors that governor's
race you mentioned that's very close the
Senate race that is drawing national
attention and seems to grow more
outlandish by the day and then
restrictive new voting laws here in
Georgia which were passed after the 2020
election that have allowed anyone to
challenge the eligibility of Voters in
counties and in local elections right
across the state that has really cogged
up the wheels of Elections here it has
also raised a lot of concern amongst
voters that people will not be able to
actually cast a ballot and that is what
we heard from voters today that is what
is drawing them to the polls nice and
early to make sure that they can vote my
primary issue with the election this
this cycle is you know access to voting
and making sure that people can you know
I probably waited close to an hour to
vote I think that's unacceptable that
was part of the reason why I was just
like let me go ahead and and vote before
things start getting crazy because I
know election day is going to be
ridiculous
so Jackson Herschel Walker as we've
mentioned up for Republican Senate in
Georgia keeps making headlines do you
think it's helping or hindering his
campaign
you know there's two ways of looking at
this one is that the electorate is so
divided along partisan lines that
Republicans will vote for any Republican
on the ballot but this race seems to be
getting more complicated with each new
Scandal you of course had the Scandal
breaking that Herschel Walker paid for
an abortion for an ex-girlfriend despite
being on a vowed anti-abortion activist
and now this Scandal where in a debate
on Friday night he pulled out a police
badge and he's been accused repeatedly
of exaggerating his ties to law
enforcement that was an honorary badge
which according to the National
Association of sheriffs is something
that belongs in a trophy case and yet
once again today in an interview with
NBC News Walker doubled down and
insisted that he has had some sort of
active role in law enforcement
this is from my hometown this is from
Johnson County from the sheriff from
Johnson County which is a legit badge
everyone can make fun but this bad give
me the right and let me finish if
anything happened in this County I have
the right to work with the police and
getting things done
so a really interesting Dynamic is
emerging here where we may see split
votes by Republicans where they may
actually vote for the Democratic
candidate Rafael Warnock and then down
the ballot when it comes to voting for
governor vote for the Republican
candidate Brian Kemp that tells you just
how bizarre this all is nephew very
likely we're back here in December for a
runoff election for that senate seat
that's how close things are right now
wow incredible and interesting indeed
Jackson prosco in Atlanta tonight thanks
Jackson
I had a high-profile opponent of
Vladimir Putin in jail how Ottawa is
targeting those who put him behind bars
[Music]
as Canada hits Russia with new sanctions
some high-profile human rights Advocates
want to see Ottawa do more in the case
of a jailed anti-putin activist Abigail
Beeman had exclusive access to some of
the group's meeting today
Vladimir karamorza is known as one of
the most influential figures behind
Canada's magnitsky-style sanctions
against Russia he was the person I would
say probably most effective in
convincing the parliament here on the
need for magnitsky sanctions the Kremlin
critic and opposition politician who has
been poisoned twice now sits in a
Russian prison charged with treason and
faces a possible 24 years there and I
just think that I'm putting one my small
nail in the coffin of this regime and
I'm gonna put it deep a team including
his wife businessman Bill Browder and
former Justice Minister and human rights
Advocate Erwin kotler are on Parliament
Hill pushing the government to use those
sanctions against the people who put him
behind bars
and I'm delighted that since this is a
place that Vladimir cameras began with
his struggle for Global magnitsky
sanctions that this is only poetic
justice that Canada should be the leader
in beginning to impose these sanctions
Monday the foreign affairs minister took
action against 34 individuals and one
entity whom she says spread
disinformation about caramurza spreading
lies and and putting his family in
danger so that was the first step step
two will Target a list of 13 judges
police officers and prosecutors directly
involved in karamor's case we can expect
those sanctions to come next I am
discovering my husband's work basically
I I now know what it looks like what it
feels like to meet with so many decision
makers in one day
to give all the interviews and all that
with the purpose of raising awareness
about what's happening not just in my
husband's case but in Russia against the
backdrop of this horrendous War Canada
has levied all kinds of sanctions
against Russia for months on the
question of whether they work the
foreign minister says these will have an
impact in this case it's also about
leadership they expect other countries
to follow Canada and invoke sanctions
targeting those connected to the Kara
morsa case Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
a warning ahead of this next story some
of the images are disturbing Greece and
Turkey are trading blame after 92 naked
migrants were discovered at the border
Greek police say they rescued the men
some injured huddled near the northern
border with turkey the migrants told
investigators they had been forced by
Turkish authorities to remove their
clothing and board three vehicles that
took them to the Border a photo that
appeared on Greek websites and on the
Twitter feed of the country's migration
Minister show several men naked and
huddled together in a wooded area turkey
calls the story fake news
a weekend fire at around notorious evine
prison which houses many of the nation's
political Prisoners has now killed at
least eight people according to
government officials new images show
some of the damage from The Blaze that
sparked Saturday night in the middle of
weeks of anti-government protests across
Iran details of the fire remain unclear
with the government saying it started
after a fight among prisoners that claim
along with the official death toll has
been disputed with some reports
suggesting the number of casualties is
higher
[Music]
perishable politics next will her
troubled tenure mean a short shelf life
for Britain's prime minister
[Music]
it is hard to overstate the political
and economic turmoil rocking the United
Kingdom right now prime minister Liz
truss has only been in the top job 41
days and already it seems pundits
bookies and the British public think her
days may be numbered how has it all gone
so wrong so quickly let us explain with
this report from Redmond Shannon Italy
that in the British House of Commons it
has now come to this
but the prime minister is not under a
desk
hardly a robust defense of Liz trust by
one of her senior ministers
on a day when the British government
navigated a mammoth reversal to save the
economy but the 180 did little to
inspire confidence in the absent prime
minister now it's time for leaders to
lead but where is the prime minister
[Applause]
hiding away dodging questions scared of
our own shadow the late is not for
turning up
trust did arrive she sat behind her
ministers at the dispatch box and left
without speaking with opinion polls
Beyond Bleak for the governing Tories
one tabloid has set up a live stream of
a head of lettuce to see if it outlasts
the beleaguered leader I've already said
on Twitter my money's on the lettuce
um I guess it depends quite how long the
letters can last I see
as some people are saying is prime
minister in name only now this is a
crisis of the government's own making
the tax cuts proposed in last month's
interim budget were not only deeply
unpopular with the public economists
said they were unfunded and unproven
tanking the value of UK government bonds
and the British pound no new taxes to
become PM trust Hong her hat on
trickle-down tax cuts referring to
opponents as the anti-growth Coalition
but leading up to Monday's U-turn she
sacrificed her Finance Minister allowing
his replacement to pull the handbrake
turns I mean it completely undermines
our entire her entire leadership
platform trust telling the BBC she will
lead her party into the next election I
will lead the conservatives into the
next general election and I want you to
know how unbelievably the British
bookies say Boris Johnson is now among
some of the favorites to replace trust
political impossible maybe but Brits are
rarely surprised by the ways of
Westminster anymore Redmond Shannon
Global News London
and that is global national for this
Monday night I'm nitu garcha tonight's
year Canada is more rain lake near bath
Alberta we love seeing your Canada
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching and hope to see you again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you